I found my dad's wedding ring at my mom's
And then I walked to the beach where Kristen was
with a bottle of champagne at sunset
And I pulled the ring out of my pocket...
Oh! Did you just think that I was proposing to you?
Shut the front door!
No
Now it's awkward
I was ready to say yes
Yeah, you were.
Are you?
It just feels like a whole big thing
that I don't really understand
Maybe do a doc?
Or something
That's a serious camera
"Domestic partnership" to me just always seemed so clinical a term
Whereas "marriage" has such a resonance of love
I want a lifetime partner
That, uh, Notebook sh*t
Can I cuss?
Yes
Domestic partnership is the easy way out
This is just so that I can have health insurance.
This has nothing to do with this other conversation
It does, okay? It does
What kept me in our relationship was,
"What's wrong with me that I can't love this woman for exactly who she is?"
I think, more and more, this is becoming about you
We're going to my dad's house
He got divorced
Was it hard for you to leave?
You don't understand how big this is
You think the water's cold?
Yep.
Do you want to walk in it anyway?